[Music]
let's talk about
jumbies
matcha pumpkin spice matcha which
matches my shirt
cold strawberry matcha cream earl grey
because i'm a distinguished gentleman
and i got a strawberry matcha fresco
mm-hmm what are you drinking delicious i
got i think i have
aloe matcha with chia seeds is that
right that's my drink oh that's
great good texture with the chia seeds
yeah once you get a bunch of those
little
in there i'm drinking both double fist
jumbie
i'm drinking a dirty matcha that was
really cool
cheese makes you feel like you got like
like a bunch of fish eggs in your mouth
almost
like yeah actually i i stopped putting
chia seeds in my drink
but too much texture oh true well now i
feel weird about it
but it's still good i got frog testicles
tapioca that's new for the month of
november right mm-hmm yeah it is frank
month
coming up is it oh okay cool that's good
to know uh let's talk about a very very
very bad person let's
let's hate on this person from subway
jerry from subway yes long video to
shout me out
true yeah so in this world there's a lot
of disgusting people
boo davidson david's uh i don't know
what's wrong with you guys you
yeah [ __ ] that i mean i hate david yeah
[ __ ] david dude we hate him
all right so in this world in this world
there's a lot of bad people
there's a lot of liars out there and
we're gonna talk about
a compulsive liar if i've ever seen one
most liars are funny they are all right
so this person
she goes by the name of sarah dele
schmidt
age 35 from illinois and now she is
guilty she's pleading guilty actually
to four felony accounts of wire fraud
and one count
of mail fraud um and what she did
usps usps yeah mail yeah
mail oh yeah what happened oh nothing i
was just like mail 1
to be a guy oh i see you are all
assuming that's not illegal
yeah that's totally yeah you had penis
eyes so i knew you were that's what
you're visualizing you did not have
penis eyes
you drew the shawls with your eyes
it's a very common thing actually so all
right she did not
pretend to die
but what you did pretend to be was
someone suffering from
muscular dystrophy spinal muscular
atrophy atrophy so she faked that
uh fake the diagnosis in 2015 2016
to go to a non-profit camp summit for
disabled people
wow what is your problem wait wait wait
wait wait wait hold on
what if the cap was sick though yeah was
that disney world
they are safe no it's uh it was in texas
what if it was like such a dope
adventure
but then you couldn't get in unless you
had something
and you really it to go then go be a
volunteer to like
help people if you want do you want to
work at disneyland or go to
disneyland
yeah because all the people that work at
disneyland they probably don't want to
go do you want to
experience business class or do you want
to be a flight attendant
no both true i don't want to be a flight
attendant
shout out to my friends who are but i
don't want to [ __ ] do that because i
don't want to serve nobody
i want to be served i don't know that's
exactly what
uh miss delishman yeah i don't want
backing up the compulsive flyer but yes
i understand the point very true but
yeah so at the camp
uh she confined herself to a wheelchair
and allowed volunteers to help bather
and dress her even though she was fully
capable that's a weird kink
doing all of that yeah it is a weirdo
trying to get money out of this what was
the reason
yeah so at these camps uh if you are
suffering from uh muscular dystrophy or
atrophy um they give you a lot of uh
you know like like you know gear like
like like you know
gear that i think she's trying to resell
or whatever for whatever value she's
doing
supreme clothes and [ __ ] yeah get they
get stuff at these uh
summits one and also she's just trying
to
uh she's trying to travel too and i
think i don't think she has the means to
travel on her own she wants that insta
influencer life huh
oh dude it gets worse all right so 2015
2016 she does that all right
fakes muscle dystrophy and atrophy
whatever and then
she gets caught by her family and i
don't know how this happens they don't
really go into detail but her family
goes to this summer this the summit and
confronts her
yeah they're like hey you lied about
this what's wrong with you
she's like [ __ ] you could stand
yeah stand up [ __ ] and stan she did she
stood up and walked away didn't say a
[ __ ] word
and left and then everyone was like i
washed her [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you could have washed it yourself how
dare you how mad would you have been
if you were in camp with her and you saw
her get up and
walk out i would want a [ __ ] not
only that but not only if you have ms if
you have ms and you saw her
do that bro you know what they should
have just all the
other guys that have most muscular
dystrophy
yeah [ __ ] her ass up he's like yo
you you took two hours longer than us at
the sponge bath you [ __ ]
you probably did milk it yeah i'm sure
she did all right so then
don't [ __ ] hit her with the
wheelchair just [ __ ] run into her
boom [ __ ] [ __ ]
the other one comes over oh yeah
so that was 2015 2016 back-to-back years
two two years in a row at the that
that particular camp in 2017 and 2018
she faked having breast cancer to attend
the young survival coalition national
summit in
florida what the [ __ ] and then at this
uh
at this summit um they're they ride
bikes uh to bring awareness for uh
breast cancer and all that stuff and
she's riding alongside
other survivors and part and part of the
perks of being a part of this
is that she gets a free bike and a lot
of just like free gear free [ __ ] she's
just finding
like uh disability places or like events
where she can reap the benefits of
whatever the
the participants get so she pretends to
have these disabilities or like whatever
it is she's [ __ ] crazy
she she's really good at researching the
past dude very very social
i want to know like what she's collected
i don't know
i kind of want to see too i kind of also
want to she's ordered
she's been ordered to give everything
back though from from uh
like uh money like they give money too
like just like
like money to help medical to help pay
medical bills and all that stuff so
she's receiving this money
and all the gear and stuff and so she's
in uh she needs to give it all back so
she kept it
she kept it for all these years until
she finally got caught yeah
and so then um i want to see her acting
skills
can we see what she's giving me a breast
cancer walk yeah this is what she looks
like when she got big-ass titties and
[ __ ]
muscular dystrophy sitting down she's
all riding a bike with her big ass
titties and all the girls are like what
the [ __ ]
did you just get it or what oh the
cancer
this is what she looks like puncher
so this is her on dr phil so she had a
whole
like uh intervention kind of thing on dr
phil she looks crazy
yeah she doesn't look very happy she
looks like she's about to stroke out
right now
true and then this is this is when she
got her plane ticket to go to one of the
the summits that she went to snap this
is her
confined confined to a wheelchair wait
did she
purchase the wheelchair so she could
fake this i don't know how far
i think so i think she had to yeah i bet
she did wow
and you might be wondering to yourself
how why these particular things
like breast cancer and muscular atrophy
and stuff like that
ailment is that one she i don't uh this
one i don't know i mean it must be an
activity at one of the sun
mummy yeah yeah maybe a halloween party
syndrome yeah yeah
but yeah this is the the bike the bike
thing
for breast cancer awareness this is
crazy yeah so you might be wondering why
these particular
um uh uh
ailments ailments yeah so she works as a
nurse and as a nurse she's tended to
uh people like this and that's how she
just goes she learned and studied
their mannerisms
so she [ __ ] memorized it and she she
acted it out so she actually did her
work
yes yeah that's correct she's obviously
very thorough
very very thorough because she she
didn't get popped until her family came
up
out of her room why can't she just buy
her own [ __ ] that she wants to buy like
no but the point of being a sociopath is
the game behind it all and [ __ ]
it's like extreme couponing this one's
talking like
[Laughter]
you guys need to understand you're not
sociopathic right
the thrill behind it is that superiority
complex for like these [ __ ] don't
know [ __ ]
so she she claims that she has a lying
addiction
on dr phil's show and um it's not my
fault to have this addiction
of lying true true so she's getting
she's getting pop for
these particular uh felony counts i
guess
but her line goes further than that so
uh
beyond these uh the the second life
uh be beyond you know living life as a
muscular dystrophy person and breast
cancer or breast cancer person
she also has faked two husbands an
entire family
yes two husbands so depending on who she
makes friends with
she'll create a whole nother persona oh
just to be friends with people she's a
secret agent
there we go there we go she has just had
two two husbands we need people like
this to work for our cia
and [ __ ] like that she just gets casted
from this
right actress give her an oscar there's
gonna be a lifetime movie
pointless talent man oh yeah how's your
recruiter
dr phil did you see the episode she was
really good
she was very convincing she does her
work
it's like those hackers that like they
get in trouble by the law and then they
hire them i think that's like catch me
if you can type
yeah that's true yeah so she's also
admitted to purchasing a four thousand
uh
basically five thousand dollar triathlon
bike with her mother's credit card wow
uh she's also uh uh done identity theft
in order to get uh medical uh uh hit
uh history medical history on other
people so that she could apply to
herself and become
the other people wow and so under her
plea deal
she is now going to receive uh
uh eight months in prison wow as to
oppose
uh how much was it 26 years in prison oh
[ __ ] why didn't she cut that down i
don't know like it doesn't really go
into detail
she's her own lawyer for sure they were
going right they were going to give her
26 years in prison for
what she was doing yeah so if she was
convicted of on all eight counts of levy
uh all eight counts of levied against
her
uh she would have faced up to 26 years
in prison
but she pleaded guilty she pled guilty
and now she's reduced so she took the
deal yeah but she's probably gonna get
out in like five
yeah i am so confused how you go from 26
years to eight months no matter what you
confess like
what kind of [ __ ] deal the
prosecutors sucked ass at their job
how did they only get eight months on
this [ __ ] i don't know
it's our justice system if she got 26
years would you guys be mad like
you'd be like yeah i feel like she is
dangerous
to society because she can create a lot
of trauma in people
with her actions yeah but then
unfortunately the way our justice system
works it's more like primal threats
right so she's like is she a murderer
and actually
she really hurt nobody maybe she hurt
him financially maybe she
broke a little bit of like um ethical
law like
going to these non-profits and like
stealing but like
literally like i just think that we need
a little bit of a shift in our justice
system because we know now like how much
psychological damage she can cause in
humans
oh absolutely bro people get go to jail
for weed for longer than that
you know yeah that's crazy that is crazy
that's our justice system
you